-We are in the Doombox.
Our next three songs will decide
tonight's champions.
It's time for
"Slay It Don't Spray It".
-♪ Better know the words
or you'll get sprayed ♪
-And here's how it works.
Players from each team will take
turns singing well-known songs
karaoke-style.
They'll have the lyrics
in front of them,
but when the music drops out,
they'll have to finish
the line from memory.
If they don't get the lyrics
exactly right,
the microphones in front of them
will spray water in their face.
But if they can slay it and sing
all of the words perfectly,
then their opponents get
drenched instead.
Each song is worth
50,000 points.
All right.
-All right.
-Nicole and Jason, your team
is up first.
Let's see what song you get.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's a good one.
-"Rolling in the Deep", Adele.
-Uh-oh.
-You have to decide
who's gonna sing.
-I like this song.
I think -- I like this song.
-Yeah, you like this?
I'll take that as,
"I'm singing the song."
-You got us, you got us.
-Really?
-How much water is coming out?
-Are you guys nervous?
-Yes.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, I know.
Me, too, a little bit.
Yeah, all right.
Whenever you're ready,
go for it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my God.
-Don't cry.
-It's gonna happen, right?
-♪ And you played it, what,
to the beat, yeah ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
[ Both scream ]
I'm sorry! Guys --
-It's more water than I thought.
-[ Laughs ]
-Jason knew he was gonna be dry.
-I knew I was good.
-Jason's, like, dancing
in there.
He's like, "I know
I'm gonna be dry."
-Yeah.
-Oh, you knew it was coming out
here.
[ Both scream ]
-So much spray.
-It is so cold.
-Ooh, sorry about that.
-Oh, my gosh, I'm scared.
-All right. Julie and Kelsea,
it is your turn.
Let's see what song you get.
[ Crowd cheering ]
-"Man! I Feel Like a Woman!",
Shania Twain.
-Whoo! Let's go!
-I feel like it's
a Kelsea Ballerini song.
-I would be nervous,
I would be nervous.
-Pressure's on.
-I don't want you to walk away
from the mics.
-I want to be right here.
-Right like this, Jimmy.
-Whenever you're ready.
-Let's do it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Here we go.
-I'm gonna go for it.
I know we're gonna get squirted,
Jason.
-I know what's about to happen.
-♪ To feel the way I feel ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I did it.
-I --
-You knew it.
-I knew it was coming.
-You knew it, you felt it.
-I committed.
-Really?
-Look at my face.
-So proud of you guys.
-Jimmy, my face is gone.
-You did a good job.
-I'm so sorry.
-That's 50,000 points
for your team.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We decided to just commit.
-It is time for the final round.
And this time, we're really
gonna raise the stakes
in this one.
Watch your heads
because we're bringing in
the big microphones.
Come on in, guys.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Season two upgrades coming in.
-Jimmy, I'm soaking wet
right now.
-Hope you brought a towel.
[ Laughs ]
-Jimmy, is this more water?
-The four of you
are going to take turns singing.
And this round is worth
200,000 points.
So whoever wins this...
-200,000.
-...wins the whole thing.
Let's see what
our final song is.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm so wet.
-"I Kissed A Girl",
Katy Perry.
-All right.
-Okay.
-Nicole, you're going
to start us off.
-I'm soaking wet.
♪♪
-♪ It felt so right,
it felt so right ♪
-♪ In love ♪
-[ Laughs ]
-[ Crowd ] Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh.
-They got it.
-It felt so right,
but it was so wrong.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We have a winner!
Julia, Kelsea are tonight's
"That's My Jam" champions!
Get out here!
-Whoo!
-There's your Boombox.
-Yeah!
-There's your golden Boombox.
-You are the champs.
Nicole, come on.
I'm -- Oh, my God.
Oh, my God.
-Do we get points
for being soaking wet?